this is a production of Cornell
University
all right everybody
um again my name is Tony ditomasso and
um
the the lab that I work in or that I
lead is is called the wheat ecology lab
uh and management lab and and as the
name suggests we study weeds both in
agronomic and in natural areas so
invasive species we particularly focus
on the biology Ecology
of these species and obviously uh as
you've uh probably saw in the news uh
invasive grasses have been a real issue
with some of those fires including but
the dafarian Maui so there's a lot of
interest again on on invasives and not
necessarily just related to to Ag
Systems
um very varied research program
um kind of all over the map but I enjoy
that I really enjoy that um again you
get an idea of some of the work that
we've been involved in kind of a major
uh Focus over the last five years has
been climate change particularly weed
distributions and what are some of the
traits of species that allow them to to
migrate basically or to move in one
Johnson grass is one that's um Growers
here in New York are particularly
concerned about this is a species that's
problematic in the South and
Mid-Atlantic States but it is now moved
into New York it's here it's been here a
while used to survive as an annual
because the winters were too cold for
the rhizomes to survive but we're seeing
that that has changed with our Winters
being milder so there's a lot of
interest and also with some um in some
of the work and and most the latest work
is on agrovoltaics and that is basically
these uh you know renewable solar Farms
some perspect by communities and just
some of you are working in this area as
well losing Prime agricultural land and
some of this work uh just got a some new
funding from New York again markets are
very interested to see can any crops be
grown on some of these these solar Farms
to at least alleviate the issue of
taking off the market some some valuable
croplands so if any of you are are
interested in kind of that that area we
can we can talk more about that
fairly large group which is I'm supposed
to be on the downside but this is uh
amazing students again you got to meet
Linnea Sophie a whole bunch of folks
Natasha I co-advised with Matt Ryan and
again uh Sarah is our newest
um uh uh postdoc when I just mentioned
he's going to be one of our
seminar speakers but does that last name
should ring a bell to some of you this
is Udi Mena yet's dad Fabian who's an
agroecologist at Montana State
University is joining our lab for a
sabbatical and is writing a book on
edible non-crop plants of which Sophie
and I have contributed a chapter but
he'll be here a great person to talk to
originally from Argentina so has a lot
to say there
um with that I do teach two courses I
should have put 2023 in there uh
currently teaching a lead science course
we have close to 25 students which is
great I also teach a graduate level
course and co-teach an IPM integrated
Pest Management course this is for the
graduate students that are out there and
undergraduate so with that uh
just right now Dr Vivan your turn
another weak science colleague thank you
Tony uh good afternoon everyone
uh my name is vipin Kumar I'm a
relatively a new faculty member here a
wheat scientist another wheat scientist
my appointment is a 60 research and 40
percent extension so I'm just a six
month six month old with Cornell
so
not a lot more to say here but a few
things we have started here this summer
just gonna tell about the projects we
are uh started here in Cornell
so uh coming here at Cornell we have
started seeing issues with the herbicide
resistance and one of the species I have
looked at this summer in the central New
York is waterhem or common water hemp
so the picture you see here these are
the pictures we got from
Central New York Cuba County Seneca
County as well Wayne County where we
have water hemp issues in field crops
like soybean and corn
and some of these fields have been
treated with the Roundup couple of times
so definitely they are resistance to
glyphosate
but my idea is to do a little survey in
the state of New York for this species
as well as other pigweed species
including Palmer including Redwood
pigweed as well as the horse weed to
look at the resistance Spectrum in the
state of New York
so we have collected some lines here
from Central New York and we're gonna
screen this in the greenhouse this this
fall or spring and we're going to screen
different herbicides the commonly used
herbicides especially 240 dicamba
gulfacinate which are very effective uh
herbicide programs for controlling these
pigweeds to see if we have any issues
with the resistance to those herbicides
along with glyphosate uh in waterhem
so as I said this is a again just a
start of the program and we have been
collecting these water hems so we're
going to collect more seeds of water
hemp as well as other pigweeds from
field crops in the state to see uh where
we stand in terms of herbicide
resistance in our weed population in the
state of New York I was looking at the
herbicide resistant International survey
and state of New York has not documented
any case since 1983. so that probably is
not true we have more cases of
resistance here
so along with the resistance screening
uh my program is gonna actively looking
at alternate herbicide options what
herbicides we can use to control these
issues like water hemp or or palmaram
rent or any other weeds so we have
started some field experimentation this
this summer looking at uh some pre and
post-applied herbicide options in
soybean as well as in corn
along with these uh chemistries we are
also looking at the application
Technologies what what spray nozzle or
spray volume we need to use for
controlling these weed species because
uh some of these new traits especially
in list soybean or extend soybeans they
specify some of those nozzles or spray
volumes we need to use and how they can
impact some of these weed control
efficacy
so this is again a lot of work in the
field this summer and we have been
looking at on-farm field studies as well
especially in central New York
especially on waterhemp what are those
alternate options we have
uh
for season act tools uh just briefly I
have a graduate student here uh akhilesh
he's here on the back he's looking at uh
the per season uh agriculture tools it's
things like drones uh he's trying to
detect uh pigweed especially water hemp
in the field crops using a machine
learning approach using different
algorithms and his interest lies in
classification of weeds from the crops
so that we can have a prescription map
where we can use those Precision
sprayers
along with those we are collaborating
with the other folks from The Grow team
looking at uh
different camera systems the camera
system on the picture here is you see
this is a 3D camera looking at
non-destructive way of measuring the
biomass the weed biomass we've been
collecting this and calibrating the
algorithms this is a group from USDA ARS
in Maryland so we're gonna do that look
at the 3D camera how we can use those
camera or sensors to estimate the wheat
biomass as well as the V densities
foreign
we also interested to look at the other
non-chemical weed control tactics the
part of my startup has given me some
money to buy this seed Destructor this
is a impact Bill we're gonna use in our
field crop especially in soybean and
gonna look at the destruction or the the
seed destruction or the pigweed seed
destruction using this tool on the back
of the combine and we are thinking to
integrate this mechanical way of weed
control along with the cultural practice
such as a cover crop how they can
integrate together in helping us
managing those resistant weeds so that's
all I have thank you
hey everybody I'm Dan Katz I'm an
assistant professor here in soil and
crop sciences and I've been here for the
last year and a half or so
um
my research focuses on the intersection
of plant ecology and public health
there are a lot of Health relevant
interactions that we have with plants
one of the ones that I focus on in
particular is allergenic pollen
now we don't have that much information
about
um Airborne pollen concentrations uh and
this is a problem because it prevents us
from doing an effective job of providing
people with forecasts and alerts and it
also uh prevents people from effectively
managing their medication and on a
broader scale we don't even fully
understand what the health consequences
of pollen exposure are a lot of my work
is to try and create these types of
models through
understanding things like where plants
are when they are reproducing and
releasing pollen how that pollen
disperses through the air and what the
health effects of it are
I also am interested in other topics
related to plant ecology and public
health and I'm working on a project now
in New York City trying to understand
whether
particular trees are especially good at
reducing temperatures during heat waves
and ultimately what can we do to
optimize the cooling effects of these
trees
especially as heat waves become more and
more in the future
so I thought I'd give you a little
example of some of the types of work
that I do and this is a project that I
did as a postdoc at the University of
Michigan
um and in this project used a bunch of
remote sensing uh to map individual
trees created allometric equations of
how much pollen individual trees
produced
and then combine these to to calculate
per tree pollen production across a
large metro area
with that uh created maps of pollen
release compared it with Airborne pollen
concentrations and also included
phenological models so that's the the
type of thing that I do uh and to do
this type of work I also uh end up
drawing from a lot of different
disciplines including remote sensing
ecology statistical modeling little bits
of Citizen science here and there and
some engineering as well as some Epi
work as well so very broad-ranging and
if you're interested in hearing more
about any of these topics or you have
some uh some interest in this kind of
intersection of plants and public health
uh stop by send me an email or chat with
Hannah thanks
all right so my Pro my Louisa I'm an
assistant professor of digital Agronomy
so my program is trying to support
farmers in their change process and the
idea is that if we want Farmers to go
from
where they are today to sustainable
agriculture this involves a lot of
change that will happen through
experimentation and figuring it out on
their Farm how to make it happen
how this can work when you think of how
digital Agronomy can support this is
that we can help farmers by
um
collecting and organizing the data then
doing those experiments in the field
interpreting and learning from those
experiments and then proceeding to
evidence-based change through uh cycles
of iteration something that could look
like a virtuous cycle that you build uh
on every year
so if you so those here are kind of the
the main line of my program but each of
those obviously will generate some
research questions that need to be
elucidated so if you look at collect and
organize data
we have one project that is
just to get a hold of the farmers Farm
the management that so those that are
everywhere like in the notepad sometimes
they are no just in their head so what
we want to do is to invent a way that
when the tractor enters a field it
triggers an interaction with a smart
speaker or something like that and then
they record their data and then it just
shuts down and then it goes directly in
the database okay so that's one example
of project we have another project here
that where when they are doing an
experimentation we can just highlight
like where was in the experiment on
their farm and then it it automatically
populates all the information for um
the weather the topography the soil type
remote sensing imagery so now you can
contextualize more and learn a bit more
from that experimentation then after
that when we proceed to experiments uh
the kind of different and fun part here
is that we let Farmers experiment the
way that fits with their business
instead of asking them to do small plots
let them experiment as the experiment
and US adapt to that process
um and then after that very important
component is to try to see how we can
create value for the farmers to really
learn from what what they did and and
continue improving
and this this was a workshop and then
after that evidence based uh so this is
how do we generate a psycho a virtuous
cycle of learning for not only selected
Farmers but for a community of farmers
that strive to to become sustainable on
their Farm
uh so this involves a lot of work from
uh social science computer science uh AI
Agronomy boots on the ground and things
like that so we have a good team uh Alex
is working on a project trying to
identify how Dynamic curves of
growth can help us better understand
nitrogen Phil is working on a project
trying to see how we can populate to
what I showed just before how we can
populate automatically some databases
and so fatty she was working on one of
the on Farm experimentation project and
we were lucky to have a bunch of interns
and collaborators across Cornell CIS the
Cedar and Cornell Tech so
just a little bit
okay so the general theme that draws my
research program together is really
using modeling to try and understand
what we can do in agriculture and
particularly soils but not only soils to
misgate climate change so some of the
things I've been doing for example are
trying to get process-based models that
actually represent how microbes turn
over carbon in soils which are much
better than the traditional types of
models we have there implementing those
kind of models into Earth system models
to actually get asked big scale
questions using these kinds of process
understanding
um start to move a lot into using AI
evidential deep learning and machine
learning techniques to try and uncover
some of the gaps of our knowledge about
processes and also to get better
predictive models for actually planning
trajectories for how we should manage
the world going into the future well I
think I've just killed the screen
okay
so some of the projects I've done and
recently are for example the top left we
can see some maps of soil carbon
sequestration potential which uh these
were the
um ones which actually made up the
projections of the recent ipcc six
assessment report and
um what we can see is what you know the
potential if we do all we can with soils
to sequester carbons it's only amounts
to a few a relatively short amount of
our emissions at the moment which tells
us two things one that we can't rely on
it to offset emissions from other
sectors we need to decarbonize massively
and this could be a sort of a another
piece of the silver Buckshot that we
need to actually solve the problem
rather than a big answer in and of
itself also look at sort of trade-offs
between different Technologies we see
between bioenergy bioenergy with carbon
capture and storage and biochar and
that's showing that biochar actually has
a niche role at allowing us to actually
tackle climate change at much lower
carbon prices than
um some of the other ways you might do
it but it might fall off later centuries
carbon prices escalate
um
I've also got this is a map from
Ethiopia where I looked at a sort of
large National survey of land
restoration prop uh program to try and
understand the mitigation potential
within that and by our child there
there's a recent map which is just in
review at the moment of trying to map
out a very high resolution globally what
we can do with agricultural messages to
uh generate biochar
it's on track and then some of the
questions that I answer I've tried to
answer with these processes for these
models are things like
um is soil carbon sequestration actually
a net sort or think of greenhouse gases
which is not actually clear yet and what
we find is actually really depends that
some systems in some places may be other
places maybe an S sorts and you really
need to think about the whole system
affects life cycle analysis soil
emissions of other greenhouse gases
long-term impacts and things like you
know even reduced tractor passes may be
more influential in the balance for
no-till than the soil use carbon used
sequester so looking at the whole big
picture and there's certainly potential
to offset around 10 percent of our
agricultural missions but not much more
again we can't use these processes to
offset other sectors just to help within
agriculture last one uh just um got
accepted yesterday so I'll go I'll
mention that which is that I used a data
from China from tens of thousands of
field trials absolutely massive data
search with some big machine learning
models to try and under tease out the
question of how much soil carbon affects
yield and so therefore how much we could
improve yield using soil carbon
sequestration turns out depends where
it's much better in drier areas in other
than wetter areas and overall globally
it's only about less than one percent
increase in crop yields if that we could
get from sequestering carbon that's a
not a huge a co-benefit there thank you
and mistakes hi Peter Woodbury so I have
broad interests in how can we improve
the productivity of both Agriculture and
Forest systems and improve the
environmental performance so soil
Quality Air Quality
um
I have I use a variety of tools to to
get at some of these questions so
geospatial modeling probabilistic
modeling and as well as process type
type modeling
and I work in a variety of scales
Watershed State and global
today I'm going to just talk about one
one group of projects related to New
York State and
we've developed a greenhouse gas
inventory for the State uh New York
state has passed very ambitious climate
legislation that requires for example
net zero emissions by 2050.
so we've
analyzed what are the emissions from
from agriculture in New York state and
the bar graph shows at the bottom that
enteric fermentation is by far the
largest source category and working our
way up manure storage both methane and
nitrous oxide again echoing Dominic's
point that we need to look at all the
greenhouse gases together very important
especially because we have carbon and
nitrogen cycling so closely together
again
um
echoing Dominic's Point agricultural
soils here especially CO2 are quite a
small source of emissions nitrous oxide
a bit higher
and the pie chart is just again
emphasizing that most of the emissions
are methane
and that's because we have such a
such a lot of livestock in New York
state
we also try to quantify greenhouse gas
emission opportunities so this is a
another analysis for the state
and reforestation we found to be the
largest that's because there are about 3
million acres by our analysis of former
agricultural land some large fraction of
that could be reforested storing a lot
of carbon
agricultural soil management that's
primarily improving nitrogen fertilizer
management so reducing fertilizer use
reducing all losses from the field
including nitrous oxide but maintaining
yields
so food waste is a bit of a placeholder
here just a nod that we need to be
thinking about the whole system so we do
inventories by sector but the way we
manage things things flow from one
sector to another so if we could reduce
food waste substantially think of all
the Upstream benefits we are requiring
all of that land all those resources all
that nitrogen that are not needed
to produce wasted food
so alley cropping is an idea of planting
rows of trees between row crops so again
trees are a theme here that there's an
opportunity to store carbon
and it looks like my time is up thanks
for getting together
um uh just because uh Tony called me out
as having been awarded um a Nas
membership I want to make uh um very
clear that this is really a team effort
um I feel all singled out but uh in a
way that's a a warp picture because I'm
working with a lot of students and a lot
of Faculty together and I want to make
also sure that others understand that
when I arrived here 22 years ago in this
department
um this uh Department as a young faculty
member was tremendously supportive to me
I think I couldn't have done it without
my faculty colleagues here feeling
welcome
um and being accepted as a young person
in this field coming from another
country having never worked in the
United States
um having no roots here I didn't know
even what a credit is and and so I feel
I feel really uh Happy
um that I can share that also with all
of you so I just want to make sure that
um that I can say that before I start
this is my only slide so I should make
up for for this Prelude
um I want to introduce a few of the
students that are um working uh in this
area
um I parsed it out into four
um broad topics that I'm interested in
to work on uh in the group and with
collaborators uh one is soil carbon soil
organic carbon mostly
um uh to look at why it is there at very
small scale so we do stuff at very very
small scale of some students such as Lee
and and Morgan uh that look at at as
fine as you can imagine pushing the
envelope on uh x-ray spectroscopy
um Rachel working on aspects of micro
microbial and and molecular diversity T
but also spinning it up into larger
scale modeling knowing knowing these
effects and and incorporating them into
models to say something about uh the
global or Regional scale uh with a lot
of other people we have
um a new Institute at Cornell that's
called the AI climate so it's an AI
Institute funded by nifa
um and uh and I want to have a lot of
discussion some of you are already aware
of that and are already part of that but
I want to draw many more people into
that and see what we can do better using
AI at all scales in terms of
agricultural and Forestry management uh
using um using computational tools
um I'm I'm very interested in uh biochar
as most of you already know
um and uh and have been exposed to uh
from things such as plant plant
communication uh to global scale uh um
effects to also interactions with the
rock weathering recycling of nutrients
as part of Sanitation especially in East
Africa looking at the opportunities but
also here locally on a dairy farm we're
just commissioning a paralysis unit on
an Upstate New York dairy farm as well
as small-scale investigations of the
opportunities to recycle in the last
area is um I'm very interested in
leveraging the humanities both in my
teaching as well as in my research to
understand how can we ask better
questions how can we investigate and
build teams better
with looking at what the Arts are doing
on the other side of the campus thank
you very much I'm Dan Buckley so I'm uh
uh soil microbiologists some of you
might know me because I'm also the
director of the MPS program here in sips
my research program uh looks at very
small things so we're interested in
microbial ecology my real focus is on
what microbes do
microbes are 4 billion years old they've
been around much longer than plants so
most plants are sharing an ancestor
maybe 400 million years old so microbes
do things that plants can't they
maintain a lot of the essential support
systems that make our planet work and
when plants want to do these things they
often partner with the microbes which is
why one of the things that Roots often
do is trying to find nutrients that are
working with those microbes in the soil
so we want to know what the microbes are
doing but that also means we need to
understand how soils operate we need to
understand how the plants operate
because it's really a three-part system
right plant microbe and soil working
together
so we're interested in how microbes get
to where they're going to be found and
what they're doing there so that
involves biogeography so this is
ecological and evolutionary what causes
the microbes to be in the place where
you find them how do they disperse but
also how do our man-made interventions
alter them so if I till the soil if I
plant one crop or another how does that
change who's there we're interested in
how they change so they can evolve more
quickly than plants and animals do and
that Evolution affects what they're
doing in the environment so we want to
understand how quickly they change what
makes them change we're also very
interested in what they do not just
who's there but but what their roles are
so we focus a lot on the carbon cycle so
we're interested in the formation of
soil carbon and also its destruction and
microbes are essential to both of these
processes and releasing nutrients from
carbon which is of course important to
plants we want to know specifically what
microbes are doing which processes and
also we're interested in a role in the
nitrogen cycle so these are two very
important things for soil fertility and
they're foundational to soil health so
we're interested as well in what are
microbial contributions to soil Health
not just as indicators which I think
they're useful indicators but also
mechanistically how do they underlie the
foundation of soil health and of course
all of this comes back to plants as well
so they're super diverse just to throw
that out there we often have students
isolating and describing new species we
name new species which is a fun thing
that a lot of biologists don't get to
say and so we're constantly discovering
new phenomena that maybe haven't been
seen before so if you have something
weird going on in your system let us
know we collaborate broadly we're
working in agricultural systems as well
as in forest ecosystems uh We've
collaborated with people who are working
on on fungi with pawpaw trees so if you
want to know what the microbes are doing
in your system let us know maybe we can
help
and our primary interest ultimately is
sort of making that link between who's
there and what they're doing we use a
lot of sophisticated genomic techniques
we use a lot of stable isotopes to try
to map function back onto microorganisms
a lot of what we do ends up revolving
around studying DNA sequences because
many of these organisms are basically
invisible and really hard to see or to
to grow in the lab and so we we pull out
their DNA and study what they're doing
from that so I think I'll wrap it up
there and
thinking is next
uh hello everyone I'm Ying I'm a social
professor in southern crop science so I
wish I could have done this last year so
this is a general overview of what my
lab is doing uh so we aim to answer two
fundamental questions the first one is
to understand how the natural ecosystem
and also managed uh systems like the
agriculture systems that respond to
climate change variability and Comics
extremes and also how these uh processes
can feed back to the climate change the
second question we aim to answer is to
how we can monitor and predict the uh
interaction between climate biosphere
and also uh hydrological Cycles so that
we can better inform policy making
so to answer the questions my lab
collaborated with economists with
computer scientists and also Engineers
so from this graph on the left you can
see that uh the skills my lab is doing
is actually very diverse from the uh
really the molecular level to all the
way to the globe
so here I try to make this for Quadrant
here
um to give you some examples of what
we're doing so from the series side uh
here
not sure where I can this upper quadrant
here we try to develop new equations uh
at the molecular molecular level to
amount of photosynthesis from light
light reaction side and we try to couple
that with the uh transpiration and also
evaporation in order to better
understand the interaction between
carbon and water cycle and we use a lot
of data if you look at this quadrant
upper here we try to both develop uh
sensing technology and a sensing
technology at The Institute level for
example at the leaf scale and also of
cannabis scale we have UAV we have
different towers and we also use a
different types of airborne and
satellite data set to understand uh the
again the interaction between carbon
water and also climate so you can see we
use a different data sets here at the
leaf level and at the canopy level and
also the region and Global level we also
develop and run model simulations here
in order to predict the past and the
future again focusing on the biosphere
and its interaction with a hypological
cycle and also uh climate change so uh
the one example here is that we try to
understand
um how the agriculture systems uh
especially the interaction of G by E by
m how that can feedback to The Climate
system in the historical period uh we
were also trying to understand how the
atmospheric CO2 changes also climate
change uh impact the trend of global
productivity evap transpiration and also
water use efficiency so we also do a lot
of applications with this modeling and
data tools Guided by our Theory so uh
one example is like we try to understand
the uh the food water and climate
sustainability uh in China and also in
Africa so last play I would like to have
this Geographic oh well graphical
illustration of what we do we basically
trying to harness the theory and the
data across different skills in order to
inform applications in ecological
monitoring forecasting and also
agriculture uh management and monitoring
so these are the sponsors for my program
that's all I have yeah
I'm Allison
and I may be the only social scientist
in your department I'm a research and a
teacher RTE faculty member here at
Cornell I've been here 10 years before
that I was in the extension system in
Dutchess County and I want to tell you
about a few of the research and
extension projects that I've worked on
it's super nice to be in this department
I'm really excited I studied ecology at
Colby College and political science and
my PhD is in international environmental
politics and policy so I've always
worked to be interaction between
stakeholders environmental agriculture
issues and policies
so I'm most excited to be joining Dr
Johannes Lehman on this new NSF AI
Institute grant that we brought to
Cornell and I'm going to be heading up
the education and extension work with
Bruce Erickson at Purdue and working
with the full team on some focus groups
and surveys and stakeholder assessment
and that's a five-year project so that's
really exciting
um I was brought into that team because
I've been working with Dr art degatano
for since I've been at Cornell for 10
years
um and developed with him the climate
smart farming program at Cornell and we
developed decision support use tools
which are on
climatesmartfarming.org and an extension
team that's out in the state working
with Farmers I conducted focus groups
that have published some articles with a
postdoc on views of Farmers on climate
change and we conducted a Statewide
survey that I'm hoping to get published
soon another project I've done I was Pi
on a nifer project to develop a climate
stewards program in New York state that
is up and running last year we we
trained nine County Extension offices on
climate change and about a total of a
hundred new volunteers across state that
work with their municipality on climate
change I'm also co-pi on a nifa project
with the University of Maryland
that looks at solar leases and we've
conducted focus groups and we'll be
working to get that data published
um I guess finally I'm lead author with
Deborah Aller on the new New York State
climate impacts assessment which should
be released this fall I co-authored the
agriculture chapter with her several
cornelians contributed to that and that
should be a really important document I
use the last
um climate report that Dave wolf led
many many times in my work and this is
an update of that and this time we
focused on climate Justice
underserved farmers and really trying to
identify adaptation practices that
farmers could adopt
I'm also working on a USDA climate
adaptation project I'm super excited
we're working with Dairy Farmers this
year to teach them about climate change
and have them develop an adaptation and
mitigation plan
so thank you so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu